[Music]
before creation itself there was six
singularity forged into Infinity stones
hey youtubers so the big news is that
Thor said that we'd be finding out about
the next infinity stone or the final
Infinity stone very very soon so we
pretty much confirmed that we're going
to see it in Thor Ragnarok which I think
most people believe the other
possibility was Black Panther so I'll
explain all the biggest theories but the
best one right now is that it rests
within Mjolnir it's inside his hammer
and it's just a really fun way for them
to twist some of the things that they've
already teased in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so there are some things that
they set up really early on in the first
Thor movie they'll explain that it's
since changed but a lot of times they
take old ideas like the Stan Lee cameo
and turn it into a big thing in
guardians of the galaxy so if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get everything there's going to be a ton
of Thor dropping really soon because
we're about to get spider-man this past
weekend Chris Hemsworth did a convention
which is a pretty rare thing the big
Avengers still do conventions they
charge a buttload of money for their
autograph I think he was charging
somewhere around $200 but they've
already finished Thor Ragnarok they
started filming his infinity war scenes
which is what that funny toy video he
posted last week was about like I'm
pissed off when people don't include me
roses just rolled in from three other
he's just a kid taking fold-over he's
not even real guns comes on cool so you
can have all the title so people were
asking all kinds of questions about Thor
Ragnarok infinity war and he was
actually pretty good about answering
them so he said a bunch of stuff about
Thor Ragnarok the soul gem was just the
biggest thing there are really three big
places that it could pop up but the most
likely like I said I think is Thor's
hammer
just because hella destroyed it so early
in the movie and if you're a big Joss
Whedon fan there's the idea of the bad
of a series like the villain then the
big bad so you have a villain like hella
who's really bad but then she gained
a secret power that makes her the
ultimate villain like the big bad so
when Chris Hemsworth teases that they're
giving Asgard a makeover that's the word
that he used it's kind of funny is
basically getting wiped off the planet
right here this is not something that
hello would be able to do all by herself
because she's been in captivity based on
the explanation of the movie like she
breaks out because Loki has been such a
shitty King while Thor's been off doing
his own thing all explained their
relationship in a second - he said some
funny things about what's going on with
Thor and Loki in the movie basically
movie's hella who's a little bit
different from comic book hella breaks
out of prison that Odin's had her in
this whole time in seeking revenge she
just wants to wipe them out of existence
so that's the whole idea of Ragnarok
Ragnarok is a much bigger Jack Kirby
concept from the comics but if you're a
longtime Thorp and they destroyed Asgard
several times in the comics in the last
20 years or so they've done just about
everything so that was the idea with
Thor Ragnarok is that Chris Hemsworth in
tiger with TD and Kevin Feige just
weren't really happy with the direction
that Thor character was going so they
picked that idea Ragnarok is a way to
soft reboot the Thor franchise in the
best way to do that is just wipe it
right off the map so you can literally
rebuild it in unless they just
mysteriously got Galactus and didn't
tell us Kevin Feige did confirm that
there's no Fantastic Four coming anytime
soon
that requires the power of an infinity
gem in what better place to let one pop
up than in a movie where you have the
most powerful Avengers battling to the
death in the arena so you see the Thor
in Traverse as you wonder how I got here
well it's a long story and then they
flashed to earth in the alleyway where
hella is breaking his hammer apart using
her power so the destruction of Asgard
is sort of like the Tia for what they
could do with the infinity gems like oh
my god if they were able to destroy
Asgard then we are really screwed there
are a lot of competing theories but the
idea of a gem being housed inside an
object has been ingrained in the MCU so
here's the original quote before
creation itself there were six
singularities then the universe exploded
into existence in the remnants of these
systems were forged into concentrated
ingots Infinity stones
these stones it seems can only be
brandished by beings of extraordinary
strength typical of humans they scratch
the surface and never fade to look
within so we've been when the infinity
gems are housed inside an object like
Loki's scepter they can still only be
wielded by beings of great power the
reason that star-lord was able to hold
on to the raw power gem for a brief
period of time is only because he's half
celestial so literally has DNA from the
most powerful beings in the universe and
that since got away they depowered him
there's a really important Doctor
Strange scene where Mordo explains why
it is that they housed these powerful
objects inside other objects we just
don't have the ability to contain these
magics so we need to bind them to
something else this is a relic some
magic is too powerful to sustain so we
can do objects with it allowing them to
take the strain we cannot I know a lot
of you are upset that we're not going to
see Adam warlock until Guardians 3 he's
not even going to be part of infinity
war he was the holder of the soul gem he
was literally inside the soul gem in the
comics but in the funny way that they
twist comic book Canon for the movies
the idea of Thor's enchantment on his
hammer how does the hammer know who's
worthy if it were not alive itself so
they did something really cool in the
comics last year where they explain that
Thor's hammer is alive it does have a
soul inside of it the comic book version
is a little bit different but you can
see how it'd be really easy to use this
for the movie and I know a lot of you
are saying what about Heimdall though he
might have the soul gem I'll explain
that next because it's a really good
competing theory but during the Thor
comic last year you learned that Odin
bound this celestial storm God to Thor's
hammer and had it forged out of a room
metal so it's a room metal plus
celestial storm God and that's how you
get your living hammer that decides
who's worthy
it literally decides like hey you're an
[ __ ] you don't get to pick me up
you're awesome
let's rock it also explains why the
hammer has so many special abilities the
ability to call down lightning because
it's literally a storm itself inside the
hammer and why he can send the hammer
away like he can literally say hammer go
away and it'll just fly off into the
distance it also explains why Odin
hasn't been wielding it because why
wouldn't the most powerful person on
Asgard
wield the most powerful weapon so Stan
Lee cameo theory of all cameo style
Marvel does funny things like that where
they take really big ideas from the
comics and do something funny with it
that helps broaden the mythology like as
of right now Thor's hammer is just
really special there's an enchantment by
Odin on it you know that it can call
down storms you've seen the things they
can do in the comics the second Heimdall
theory is also really good too because
it also explains some of his crazy
powerful abilities he's one of the most
powerful people on Asgard - he stands
there on the Rainbow Bridge and he can
see pretty much anything that you ask
him to see in the multiverse they do a
better job of it in the comics where you
see the galaxies in his eyes where it's
like oh my god it's like the entire
universe contained inside his head he
can pinpoint anything anyone so the idea
that he could pick out souls is a fun
way of explaining that he might have the
soul gem that gives him that broad
ability but I know a lot of you still
want to hold out for Black Panther the
thing about Black Panther it could
totally be inside the heart tree where
the heart-shaped herb grows the Black
Panther takes it's inside the necropolis
it's a very cool concept because they
get into the Dajjal eeeh sort of the
spirit plane so there's a lot of soul
related things and spirituality in black
panther they have the vibranium so I
feel like it's already special enough
there would be reason enough for Thanos
to want to attack Wakanda during
infinity war and that's assuming that
they don't take one of the infinity gems
that they already have and hide it in
Wakanda so that's also a possibility -
but there are a lot of people wondering
recently because they showed some behind
the scenes of Wakanda I even did a video
for it because Hulk is there so it's
like what are the Avengers doing in
Wakanda that's so important why with a
nose come for them probably because they
have an infinity gem with them it has
this big convention Chris Hemsworth did
tease some of the infinity war villains
so I might do a separate video about
that he was talking about Black Order
but there will be villains from each
other's movies so if you're holding out
hope for Red Skull to return infinity
war it's a
as possible but they haven't said
anything about him coming back so let me
know in the comments what's your best
soul gem theory I know there's all this
talk about spider-man venom MCU I'll
link that video at the end of this but
they also teased multiple spider-man
pose credit scenes so I'll be doing a
video for that I also have some American
Gods finale to post but leave all your
requests for Marvel videos in the
comments below but congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner the Atlas
plays please private message me so I can
get your contact details while you wait
for everything click here for that funny
venom MCU teaser and click here for
brand new Game of Thrones thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight